[Music]
alright guys I'm gonna show you a photo
and you have to guess what's happening
here oh shoot I like this game
Dumbledore Snape killed him oh the whole
time measuring out their coffins uh any
other guesses
there are coffin makers and they're just
taking a nap during the walking through
a door from a construction site they're
played they're playing the mummy game
they're on like a bootleg Fear Factor
and about to get scorpions dumped on are
they two races Mexicans want to make
Corona Asian jokes or there are two tiny
Mexicans that are like hey let's see if
I can fit in these drawers I did they
did helps Akins you could buy a Mexican
now okay we're just got a home depot
packaging no these are the next of the
homies dolls that you get including the
construction worker now for starters
they are Peruvian I'm Mexican
oh my bad awesome so one of these men is
a mayor of a small town in Peru and the
other ones dead no the other ones is Oh
me
and so they so the mayor and a few of
his friends decided to break quarantines
and just go get [ __ ] shit-faced yeah
what ended up happening is when so they
were so drunk so loud that people call
the cops and once they heard sirens they
decided to jump into these open caskets
that weren't built out for kovat oh my
god they're like we're gonna pretend
like we're dead
yes oh my god they were trying to
pretend to be dead
wouldn't get caught for breaking point
had the mayor pull the mayor card though
when the cops roll up
apparently not he thought this was a
great idea then the cops took a picture
of that or he was like he was shit-faced
and then it just took him back to his
like old school days here decided to go
[ __ ] the cops the cop dude forget it so
[ __ ] up his friends like well you can
do something here the mayor he's like
I'm [ __ ] everyone why would the mayor
be like not allowed to walk around the
streets well because of the whole like
regulations right now you know like the
whole quarantine stuff and the entire
country of Peru everyone's like trying
to do stay-at-home order and but yeah so
they ended up thinking this was a great
genius I did something the cops when
they approached them they were like
isn't that the mayor yeah well I don't
know if they recognized them immediately
it's go to the mess but the thing that
made them to crack up is that they were
trying to be so like this look at this
fall he was promoting their head oh my
he's shot - so it's moving oh look how
tiny started I think you can for sure
seen breathing under like these bodies
like as if they would very uh like dead
people with the mask on right that's the
point it should be naked trust me that
the undead like oh the Hulk's that are
that are pretending to die or like hide
like kids it's the funniest [ __ ] on
earth these full-stop that this was
gonna give to funny there's a [ __ ]
stupid it's like if they're if they had
a pole they're hiding behind the pole
just thinking that the cops not gonna
see of it you never did [ __ ] like that
like what was a crease as our child not
even a king
school you didn't have the heart as a
mayor also Yahoo ever built these
caskets is like like the measurements
are like perfect for you for these guys
huh is the whole city like the same
height or what Haman is Tommy are like
the same high yeah they tried on a few
on for size like oh this one fits us
yeah maybe we look better dead than this
one yeah he's so erect well they're
trying to be like all [ __ ] stiff
throw me the heads floating in [ __ ] oh
yeah it's so ridiculous and like they
like he had literally been made for a
fool in like in the media and stuff
everyone's making fun of him like how
the [ __ ] was he gonna think that this is
okay he could go you could get away with
it do you try to pass it off though like
how we're just trying to like you know
get out of our systems a little sleep a
little bit I wouldn't have owned this
[ __ ] no [ __ ] way I'm never owning
that that's so embarrassed maybe he's
like I don't to make sure the cops are
doing their jobs and you guys did a good
job you silent yeah I gave you a civic
medal always like I care so much about
our people I want to make sure that
these coffins are the right measurements
for when you guys I want to make sure
that the coffins were comfortable for
the people that are from kovin no more
uncomfortable coffee business yeah
reelect me for no more I make sure that
the coffins are good you won't go by oh
great you guys are here too you know
this is 30 playing it off and I want to
see what happens yeah it's good material
yeah
all right yes who made this I want to
reward them yeah like earlier in the
month this this mayor he was getting a
lot of like criticism because of the
fact that he he has failed to implement
emergency coronavirus quarantine
shelters and like or creating safety
checkpoints to make sure make sure that
people from the outside of like outside
of town I couldn't enter or at least be
screened he's like what how can I do
that I was getting [ __ ] up with my
friend huh guys aren't even listening to
me you expect me to do all this work
dude I got a drink - yeah and then
apparently they're saying that he has
allegedly been in the town for just nine
out of the last seventy three days of
national logs down so where was he I
don't know but it's just really they're
pretty much painting the picture he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about it well he got
voted in right like who the [ __ ] boat is
this guy in yeah votes for anybody
that's true the seniors senior citizen
through yeah I think the real voters are
the seat like if you go campaign at a
[ __ ] Retirement Center you're gonna
win cuz they're [ __ ] bored dude yeah
it's like it's like Tim's dad gonna buy
a [ __ ] wall mantis or whatever so
[ __ ] boring buddy like people
campaign at universities and [ __ ] and
they're like the most vocal and then
nobody goes to vote it's the funniest
[ __ ] I don't know because I'm not
criminal minded um I don't know what I
would have done I think I've PO would
ended up in the same situation if I was
you would have been like oh [ __ ] the
cops yeah my full guide and I'm drunk I
think I would have done the same thing
I would have just been like hey it's me
marriage Mayor Pedro you have to act
drunk though yeah you're not sober man
Pedro girl if I was gonna be out in town
I would at least be just wearing a suit
all the time just in case I can pass off
I'm doing some like Oh city work have a
suit under your chill clothes so you
could ditch the chill clothes
it looks like sweating some [ __ ] ring
around your t-shirt you see the skies
hanging out with another politician
cousin if you get caught with that guy
who's he
the gold farmer yeah he was trying to be
a commenting you had to blend in you
gotta you gotta hang out with other
dignitaries they eat a lot of guinea pig
in Peru
have you tried about qui yeah GUI you've
tried it
yeah yeah is it good it's interesting
but what kind of preparation did you tie
it was it like the first book I forgot
already good but cuz uh Casey's parents
they went to Peru and they had guinea
pig and they said they prepared it two
different ways
and like one way was way grosser than
the other way nervous almost fried it's
other one was steam one had the firaon
stuff oh no well they they for sure
well they leave the head on the way not
when I had it which is which is the part
that making gifts that's the part that
throws you off the most you know it's
right cute I don't want to see [ __ ]
head on my plate you're right there's
risk yeah and um guinea pigs are cute
they're [ __ ] cute the skin of it look
like a kind of like a duck the way the
skin was kind of like brown and crispy
and then the texture of the meat is uh
is a little more like a pork duck
combination like ham Street yeah really
similar to the back no no it's
surprisingly not like rad design if you
want to see that episode watch acquired
taste
on Thrillist were you at were you in the
bedroom eating that no no no as a
Peruvian restaurant in New York how was
this season some pepper naughty Watson
no it was a bunch of [ __ ] took a bunch
of he like he like marinade like rubbed
it all down and they put enough info
where do you get guinea pig out here
though that yeah
so so a part of the episode that we
didn't get shown is we went to a farm
outside of like on the outskirts of like
the city of New York and then it's like
he had like a guinea pig farm farm
what's poppin animal it was a real ass
no no no it's not popping that hard but
he specifically was one of the farms
that like you know I this one's for food
for yeah this is for the restaurants
that this is do that yeah cuz the one
that you buy is Pez they're skinny maybe
you should feed yours yeah they're not
supposed to be very poufy their poufy
they're proof bed wait was it was it
dryer like we see it was okay it was
juicy well so the skin looks like it
would be as thin as like some duck skins
so if you feel like it'll be crispy then
you cut into it it's a little harder to
cut into and then yeah the skins kind of
tough but then the meat is juicy yeah
well I mean there's Peruvian restaurants
here all over but yeah I never even
thought about you weren't looking for
[ __ ]
that's what I thought you're gonna say
he's like yeah in Peru they call it
guinea pig same words my nephew had a
guinea pig that [ __ ] live for
like ten years or some [ __ ] and it heard
every time he gave them carrots but yeah
it pursed but it's just sweet for one
person though but this is how it ordered
I'm like y'all get the Queen and
headless please thanks so much it
definitely throws you off a little bit
when you see that head on there
yeah yeah what about when you get duck
or whatever no cuz you used to it I mean
it's something less like jarring uh
seeing a bird head than it was a mouth
open oh yeah cuz my I went with my dad
to China and they [ __ ] got I forgot I
was calling squab or some [ __ ] and this
fool came out like
and I could they fried it with the mouth
closed like a tiny chicken put the duck
in this position to have it look like
this
close the [ __ ] mouth
damn you imagine like a Thanksgiving
turkey and as we like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]